over the last month we have been testing
these new MacBooks like crazy and I know
we have made more content than anyone
else and while these machines are very
nice and very fast they definitely have
their downside so in this video I want
to make it very easy for those of you
guys that want to buy one to know all of
the issues and problems before you spend
your hard earned money and that makes it
easy so you don't have to watch all of
those videos for the first one if you
are a video editor like we are you have
to know that even though the performance
is incredible the actual encoders are
identical so if you're spending
$1,600 or even
$2,000 on one of these MacBooks the
encoding speed is going to be exactly
the same as a $750 M1 MacBook Air that
came out in
20120 and unless you're putting in a ton
of crazy effects that are going to just
push the system like crazy you might not
notice any difference in terms of
regular 4K editing number two is battery
life especially with the M3 Max model
the hardware is so fast that it uses a
ton of power and you get about 2 hours
less battery life than you do on the M2
Max version now here is a chart from
Tom's Hardware that is excellent with a
lot of systems you guys can see that
difference but on the positive the base
M3 14in actually does incredibly well
because of its large battery size to
Performance ratio and for number three
is how hot and how loud these machines
can get especially the M3 Max this thing
uses almost as much power as the very
best Intel chips and a lot of times it's
the same because of that the fans kick
up really fast it gets hotter than
before at least at the start and it can
get loud and annoying now with that the
$1600 M3 model that has a single fan
that also gets hotter and much louder
than before with the 14-in models
because Apple cut a fan out so if you
care about it being quiet keep that in
consideration now I will say I made an
excellent low power mode video that is
absolutely shocking so if you're looking
into getting M3 Max and you care about
noise and heat definitely watch that
number four is the last one with the M3
Max performance and that is the 14in
model pre previously we saw that the
14-in would be quite a bit slower than
the 16-in model and this year it is a
lot worse because the 14in just gets so
hot that it slows down a ton and it
makes the M3 Max perform more like a pro
chip instead of a Max chip so if you
care about performance and you want to
get a Max chip you definitely should get
a 16-in now for number five we're going
down to that $1,600 new M3 machine and
one thing that a lot of people don't
talk about is that it's actually missing
a thunderbolt port on the machine
compared to all the other 14-in models
and this is something that I even keep
forgetting myself and that can be a good
difference if you're going to be
connecting different accessories that's
another reason to spend a little bit
more now with that for number six is
that this $1600 machine that can go up a
lot more if you upgrade it can only
support One external display even though
it has an HDMI port and it has multiple
Thunderbolt ports you are still limited
um so if you care about that you might
want to spend a little bit more money
especially if you're going to upgrade
the RAM and that is the next one the 8
gigs of RAM severely slows the system
down because even just launching the
system you're using close to 6 gigs of
RAM just for Mac OS and then when you
start to open web browsing tabs some
applications it is just much slower and
even even if you don't have multiple
programs the 16 gig version is so much
quicker just because that's extra RAM
and with that some programs won't even
let you use Graphics acceleration cuz
there's not enough RAM now in the past 8
gigs was not as big of a deal because
the processors like the M1 weren't as
fast but now it's a much bigger
bottleneck and for number eight I
actually mentioned this in number three
um which I wasn't going to well that is
just that single fan in this system
which makes it hotter and louder than
before so I will add in even though we
have this new cheaper Mac with this new
form factor by the time you do some
upgrades you might as well get the
$2,000 M3 Pro because it absolutely
blows it away in pretty much every way
it's a much better bank for the buck and
for number nine we have the price
increases even though we have that
cheaper model if you take a look at the
max models which have the best
performance it's actually more expensive
before it was 3,500 to get the best CPU
graphics performance but now it cost
$4,000 and with that people ask is it
worth it we actually made a video
comparing all of the chips it's an
excellent video and the $4,000 one does
actually give you better value for the
money because you not only get better
performance but you actually get more
RAM as well and number 10 is another
little sneaky move that Apple did this
year to get you to spend more money
because now you you only get the best
CPU performance if you get a Max chip
and the $44,000 model the previous two
generations you can get a pro chip so an
M1 or M2 Pro and you'd get the same CPU
performance as spending $1,000 more on a
Max so if you didn't use heavy Graphics
you could save some money but now
they've split the lineup so well that it
just makes you spend more money even if
you don't need extra Ram or graphics
performance for the first time ever
Apple actually went down down in terms
of performance cores and in terms of
Graphics cores for this system so much
so that in some tests it's actually
slower than the M2 Pro and with that
they dropped the memory bandwidth by
25% on this as well and that also can
suck in some programs now thankfully
they've done a lot of other great things
with this chip so in some real world
tasks it could be much faster but it
really depends on what you're doing and
this is where I would really look into
our detailed comparisons before you make
your decision and next we have to talk
about the storage and the speed if
you're spending $2,000 you're still
going to get quite a bit slower storage
than you could back two generations ago
because they're using less nand chips
inside so this is where I'll say that if
you're on the fence upgrading to one
tbyte you're not only going to get
double the storage for 200 bucks but
faster speeds as well so I would push
you if you're on the fence just to spend
a little bit bit more money and for the
last one number 13 this is another thing
that they switched and now if you want
to get a high amount of storage if you
have a need for that and the money you
can no longer do that with a pro chip
before you could now you have to upgrade
to a Max chip in order to get um extra
nans on the motherboard because they are
just limiting it now and that's another
way to get you to spend more money so
even though we really like these
machines other than that $1,600 model
because the value for the money is much
worse than spending 400 bucks more um
they are great but you are going to be
paying for those improvements where in
the past the prices stayed pretty much
the same or maybe just made the machine
slightly worse in some areas and some
people have also mentioned that now for
that $1,600 machine the bios for the
logic board and the motherboard is on
the memory chips so if you get a low one
with low Ram your memory will actually
wear out quicker and then if it wears
out you have to spend 7 to 900 bucks on
a new logic board where before you could
pay somebody to swap out the chip for
you it's another cost savings that they
put into that base machine so I guess
that will be a bonus number 14 so thank
you guys for watching uh make sure to
check out the other comparisons because
we have much more info and a lot of
positive things to talk about click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos right over there
this has been and I'll see you in the
next one